die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis schönen guten Abend und
herzlich willkommen was im Sport los war
das erfahren Sie von Norbert Lehmann
unter anderem auf diese Themen blicken
wir
neues Gesetz für bessere Integration
Ausländer sollen künftig schneller die
deutsche Staatsangehörigkeit beantragen
können
historische Weltraummission geglückt
Indien landet erfolgreich auf dem Mond
als vierte Nation nach den USA der
Sowjetunion und China
und weltgrößte computerspielmesse in
Köln auf der Gamescom dreht sich alles
um die neuesten Trends der Branche
[Musik]
um zwei große Themen die für
Diskussionen sorgen ging es heute im
Kabinett zum einen wurde der Weg dafür
frei gemacht dass Menschen leichter
ihren geschlechtseintrag und ihren
Vornamen selbst bestimmen können dazu
kommen wir gleich als erstes schauen wir
auf den Gesetzentwurf der ist
eingewanderten Menschen leichter machen
soll die deutsche Staatsangehörigkeit zu
erhalten so sehen die Details aus
statt wie bisher nach acht sollen
eingewanderte künftig nach fünf Jahren
eingebürgert werden können Frauen und
Männer die schon besonders gut
integriert sind etwa durch ein Ehrenamt
nach drei Jahren
außerdem soll es für alle möglich sein
mehrere Staatsangehörigkeiten zu haben
grundsätzlich soll die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft nur bekommen wer den
Lebensunterhalt aus eigenen Mitteln
bestreiten kann lass Bonsack
auch wenn die Nationalhymne ein bisschen
traurig klingt eine Einbürgerungsfeier
wie diese in Hildesheim ist für die
Beteiligten etwas ganz Besonderes ich
erkläre feierlich dass ich das
Grundgesetz und die Gesetze der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland achten und
alles unterlassen würde was ihr schaden
könnte solche Feiern soll es künftig
häufiger geben die Bundesregierung will
die Einbürgerung deutlich vereinfachen
und beschleunigen ein Grund dafür ist
der massive Fachkräftemangel in
Deutschland
wir werden die besten Köpfe in der Welt
aber nur gewinnen wenn sie ihn
absehbarer Zeit voll und ganz Teil
unserer Gesellschaft werden können mit
allen demokratischen Rechten denn nur
wer die Perspektive hat auch deutsche
deutscher werden zu können und hier eine
vollständige Heimat für sich und seine
Familie zu finden wird sich auch für
Deutschland entscheiden eine
Einbürgerung ist aber nur möglich wenn
die Antragsteller ihren Unterhalt selbst
bestreiten und keine Sozialhilfe
beziehen dennoch ist die Kritik von
Union und AFD massiv die Bundesregierung
sendet die falschen Signale und
verschleudere die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft müsste erst einmal
danach schauen dass sie die irreguläre
Zuwanderung insbesondere nach
Deutschland entsprechend steuert ordnet
und auch begrenzt und sie macht genau
das Gegenteil der deutsche Pass darf
doch allenfalls Abschluss sein
gelungener Integration wird jetzt aber
früh vorab verscherbelt und der
Doppelpass untergräbt eigentlich jede
Identifikation mit Deutschland und da
das Gesetz nicht in den Bundesrat muss
könnte es bereits in diesem Herbst
verabschiedet werden und Anfang 2024 in
Kraft treten
Menschen die sich nicht mit dem
Geschlecht identifizieren das nach der
Geburt eingetragen wurde sollen künftig
einfacher ihren geschlechtseintrag und
ihren Vornamen ändern können das hat das
Kabinett heute beschlossen jetzt kommt
das selbstbestimmungsgesetz in den
Bundestag das bisherige Verfahren wird
von den Betroffenen als langwierig teuer
und entwürdigend kritisiert
seit Jahren kämpft der Bundesverband
Trans für eine vereinfachte
geschlechtliche Selbstbestimmung
männlich weiblich divers oder weder noch
dazu waren bislang ausführliche
psychiatrische Gutachten erforderlich
plus Gerichtsverfahren damit soll nun
Schluss sein jede Person überlegt sich
wirklich über mehrere Monate und Jahre
was ist der nächste richtige Schritt im
Leben und da kann eben die Änderung des
geschlechtsantrag einer dieser Schritte
sein und da ist es auch wichtig keine
unnötigen Hürden aufzubauen die Ampel
hat nun die Weichen gestellt das
sogenannte
selbstbestimmungsgesetz künftig soll
jeder ab dem 14 Lebensjahr einmal pro
Jahr Vorname und Geschlecht ändern
können Minderjährige nur mit Zustimmung
der Eltern wer ich bin das weiß nur ich
selbst und das gilt auch für die
geschlechtliche Identität
und darüber selbstbestimmt entscheiden
zu können dass es ein Menschenrecht mehr
als 600 Jugendliche hat Psychiater Roma
in den vergangenen zehn Jahren begleitet
junge Menschen die das Gefühl haben im
falschen Körper zu stecken oft
konfrontiert mit Ängsten Depressionen
Suizidgedanken deswegen ist es eine
große Erleichterung für Betroffene wenn
sie den Weg unkomplizierte gehen können
zumal wie wir wissen es sich nicht um
eine Krankheit handelt sondern um eine
Norm Variante der menschlichen Natur so
wie die Homosexualität auch
kritiker fürchten insbesondere
Jugendlichen viele die nötige Reife für
so eine folgenschwere Entscheidung
offensichtlich
wir werden Menschen dazu ermutigt sich
mit bestimmten
Klassifikationen sich zu identifizieren
statt einfach
Mann oder Frau Junge oder Mädchen zu
sein und sich frei zu entwickeln ein
umstrittener Gesetz Entwurf den
Betroffene mehrheitlich begrüßen über
den im Herbst im Bundestag abgestimmt
wird
und mehr dazu gibt es um 20 Uhr bei ZDF
heute live in der ZDF heute App und auf
unseren Social Media Kanälen außerdem
erklärt unser Online-Team in der ZDF
heute App wen das neue
selbstbestimmungsgesetz betrifft und wie
es funktioniert
jetzt sind die Ukraine dort gibt es
weiter heftige Kämpfe um strategisch
wichtige Städte so auch umkunft vor
einem Jahr konnte die Ukraine die Stadt
befreien nun Rücken wieder russische
Truppen vor die Einwohner von kubians
werden inzwischen in Sicherheit gebracht
die Stadt ein wichtiger
Verkehrsknotenpunkt liegt in der Region
hagriff und 50 km von der russischen
Grenze entfernt Anne broe berichtet
zum letzten Mal geht Irina terrassenko
durch ihr Haus in dem sie 23 Jahre lang
gelebt hat jetzt wartet sie darauf
evakuiert zu werden
es ist sehr schwer das hier ist meine
Heimat an einen fremden Ort zu fahren
auch wenn es da gut ist ist schwer aber
ich habe keine Kraft mehr das zu
ertragen
freiwillige vom Roten Kreuz helfen ihr
und ihrer Schwester mit dem Gepäck ein
paar Plastiksäcke Rucksäcke mit dem
Nötigsten alles muss schnell gehen die
nächsten warten schon es ist deine
gefährliche Mission seit zwei Wochen
laufen die Evakuierungen hier in
kopiansk während die Russen weiter auf
die Stadt vorrücken das macht die
Rettungsaktion so gefährlich denn immer
wieder werden die Fahrzeuge beschossen
die die Menschen in Sicherheit bringen
sollen überall sehen wir ukrainisches
Militär sonst wirkt die Stadt wie
ausgestorben von
27.000 Einwohnern sind nur ein paar
tausend geblieben sie wollen nicht gehen
trotz Dauerbeschuss
das ist schlimm ja das ist normal hier
wir haben uns schon daran gewöhnt wir
wissen schon wie und wohin es fliegt
wohin soll ich das ist in der ganzen
Ukraine so
drei Kinder sieben Erwachsene zwei Hunde
haben es in die evakuierungsfahrzeuge
geschafft alles gut gegangen
wir wissen nie wann es Beschuss geben
wird wir riskieren es einfach heute hat
sich das Risiko gelohnt alles hat
geklappt
es geht nach in eine Notunterkunft erst
mal weit genug weg von der Front
in Griechenland brennt es seit Tagen und
das Ausmaß ist immens weite Teile des
Landes liegen unter dichten
Rauchschwaden der Wind macht es den
Einsatzkräften derzeit enorm schwer die
Feuer unter Kontrolle zu bringen
besonders schlimm wüten die Flammen im
Nordosten unter anderem betroffen der
das Jahr Nationalpark aber auch nördlich
von Athen lodern die Flammen mehr von
Andreas Postel
sie sollen sich vor den Feuern in
Sicherheit bringen und ihre Ortschaft
verlassen und der noch bleiben Sie hier
um Haus und Hof zu retten in Arier
paraske wie einem vor Ort nordöstlich
von Athen fühlen Sie sich von den
Rettungskräften im Stich gelassen
die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist für jemanden
der bei seinem Haus bleibt größer sein
Haus auch zu schützen ansonsten wäre das
hier alles schon abgebrannt
20 Jahre lang habe ich an diesem Haus
gebaut und in 5 Sekunden kann das
Niederbrennen
eine sehr tragische Situation nur dieses
Haus ist verschont geblieben alles
andere ist abgebrannt
die Einsatzkräfte können nicht überall
gleichzeitig sein rund um Athen sind sie
mit 65 Löschzügen mit Flugzeugen und
Hubschraubern im Einsatz auch
Deutschland Hilft mit zwei
Löschflugzeugen insgesamt brennt es in
Griechenland an mindestens 15 größeren
Fronten in den vergangenen fünf Tagen
musste die Feuerwehr gegen 355
Waldbrände vorgehen
es ist der schlimmste Sommer seit Beginn
der Aufzeichnung meteorologischer Daten
und seitdem die Karten zur
Waldbrandgefahr im Land herausgegeben
werden
besonders heftig brennt es seit Tagen
rund um die Hafenstadt alexandropolis
und auch im Nationalpark Daria na der
EU-Außengrenze zur Türkei waren binnen 2
Stunden 12 Brandherde aus als Ursache
wird auch hier Brandstiftung vermutet
die Verbitterung darüber ist sehr groß
die Staatsanwaltschaft in Athen hat nun
die Ermittlungen aufgenommen
in Indien haben heute sehr sehr viele
Menschen mitgefiebert und es hat
geklappt eine indische Sonne ist auf dem
Mond gelandet das ist das es ist bisher
nur drei Staaten gelungen und Indien ist
das erste Land dessen Sonde in der Nähe
des kaum erforschen Südpols auf der
Mondoberfläche aufsetzte mehr dazu von
Thomas
14:34 Uhr unsere Zeit die Animation
zeigt es live Sonne Schand drei Jahren
drei setzt auf Jubel setzt an der
Premierminister mit Nationalflagge und
mit stolzer Botschaft
Indien ist nun auf dem Mond zum ersten
Mal darauf hatten sie gehofft seit dem
Start der Trägerrakete vor gut einem
Monat Feuer und Flamme fürs Projekt die
weltweit größte Bevölkerung Schulklassen
schicken Wünsche gläubige Hindus Gebete
vom heiligen Ganges in himmlische Höhen
dort glückte Indien nun erst als viertem
Start eine unbeschadete Ankunft auf dem
Erdtrabanten ein internationaler
Prestigegewinn auch wenn Kritiker sagen
der Subkontinent solle sich besser um
irdische Belange kümmern um die Armut um
die Not im eigenen Land
doch ohne Zweifel Indien schafft was
Russland noch am Wochenende misslang
Luna 25 zerschellt sollte auch zum
Südpol des Mondes dort ist Indien als
erstes Land überhaupt dort soll es
tatsächlich in komplett abgedunkelten
Grad in die niemals Sonnenlicht sehen
auch vermutlich Wasser geben und das
wäre natürlich für
zukünftige wohnstation eine
hervorragende
Indien ist auf dem Mond und will noch
weiter Planungen laufen für Missionen
zum Mars und zur Venus
zurück nach Deutschland
Amokalarm heute morgen an einer
Grundschule im sächsischen Bischofswerda
ein Jugendlicher hat mit einem Messer
einen achtjährigen Jungen schwer
verletzt danach versuchte der 16-Jährige
sich selber anzuzünden so die Polizei
der Jugendliche der früher selbst auf
der Schule war konnte festgenommen
werden bei dem Verletzten Grundschüler
bestehe keine Lebensgefahr so die
Polizei er befinde sich in einer Klinik
die Hintergründe der Tat sind weiter
unklar
wer zur Zeit eine Ausbildungsstelle
sucht hat gute Karten noch sind rund
230.000 Ausbildungsplätze zu haben
trotzdem bleiben viele Jugendliche außen
vor das liege vor allem daran dass ihnen
grundlegende Qualifikation fehlten sagen
die Arbeitgeber die Gewerkschaften
halten dagegen viele Betriebe wollten
noch immer nur die besten auswählen
außerdem müssten sie die Ausbildung
attraktiver machen Markus groß berichtet
Mahlzeit Dieter miesen auf
baustellenvisite der Prokurist kümmert
sich um Personal und Ausbildung wie
jedes Jahr sucht der Tiefbau
Facharbeiter und Kanalbauer die zehn
Ausbildungsplätze bekommt der Berliner
Betrieb derzeit nicht besetzt wir haben
rückläufige Bewerberzahlen und eine
rückläufige Qualität von Jahr zu Jahr
denken wir wir haben die Talsohle
erreicht aber es geht noch weiter nach
unten laut neuester Umfrage fanden 47%
der Betriebe im letzten Jahr nicht
genügend Auszubildende
überdurchschnittlich betroffen dass
Gastrogewerbe die Industrie und die
verkehrsbranche
der Wettbewerb um die weniger jungen
Leute ist sehr intensiv wir haben heute
weit über 100.000 weniger
Schulabsolventen als vor zehn Jahren das
merkt man weil gleichzeitig viele
Menschen in Rente gehen haben wir einen
starken Engpass mit tiktok und
instagram-videos auf Personalsuche
selbst kleine Betriebe versuchen
inzwischen mit Kurzfilmen Spaß am Job
rüberzubringen möglichst authentisch und
nah am Arbeitsalltag die Zielgruppe
junge Leute zwischen 16 und 22 Jahren
die Stelle aufmerksam geworden und zwar
wurden mir ganz viele werbeclipse
angezeigt oder allgemein von der Firma
und dann hat sie mir gefallen wir hatten
im Vorfeld gar keine Bewerbung mehr und
haben die Mitarbeiterzahl jetzt in den
letzten drei Jahren mehr als verdoppelt
für das kommende Ausbildungsjahr sind
die Zahlen insgesamt wieder etwas
positiver aus ein kleiner
Hoffnungsschimmer für Dieter miesen und
seine Tiefbaufirma
und gerade wird gemeldet in Russland ist
ein Privatflugzeug abgestürzt es soll
mindestens zehn Tote geben nach
offiziellen Angaben steht der Name von
Söldner Chef prigosh ihn auf der
Passagierliste mehr dazu bisher nicht
bekannt
in Köln hat die gamescom die weltgrößte
computerspielmesse begonnen
für die deutschen Hersteller und
Anbieter geht es weiter aufwärts
4,7 Milliarden Euro Umsatz im ersten
Halbjahr plus 4 Prozent im Vergleich zum
Vorjahreszeitraum je jünger die
Nutzerinnen und Nutzer desto mehr Geld
geben sie allein für Spieler aus die
16-29-jährigen mit 30 Euro pro Monat
doppelt so viel wie die ab 65 Jan Hofer
und Ralf Goldmann über die Faszination
gamescom
in fremde Welten eintauchen und in
andere Rollen schlüpfen das große
Versprechen der
Computerspielindustrie lockt Tausende
auf die gamescom die Messe selbst sieht
sich eher als großes Festival hier
feiert sich die Spielewelt
dass viele verschiedene Personen auch
hier sind aus vielen verschiedenen
Ländern alle kommen hierher alle kommen
zusammen und alle haben eine
Leidenschaft das Game
ja es ist und um auch mal so ein
bisschen der Realität zu entfliehen ein
Trend auch in diesem Jahr vernetztes
spielen online über Landesgrenzen hinweg
zusammen im Team oder gegeneinander
multiplayer spiele boomen da geht's um
das gemeinsame Spielen als Familie mit
Freunden mit Spielerinnen und Spielern
weltweit und das sehen wir gerade auch
hier auf einer gamescom wo die Menschen
zusammenkommen wo sie sich treffen um
einfach auch ja die Freundschaften zu
pflegen die ansonsten in virtuellen Raum
passieren die meisten Blockbuster Spiele
die hier für Aufregung sorgen werden im
Ausland produziert doch auch die
deutschen Entwickler holen auf Deck 13
z.B ist dieses Jahr mit einem eigenen
Game vertreten Atlas fallen kämpft man
sich in seinem Rollenspiel durch eine
große Wüstenlandschaft es ist alles sehr
auf Erkundung ausgelegt viele
Geheimnisse die man entdecken kann und
ja ich glaube spricht eine relativ
breite Masse an die gamescom läuft noch
bis Sonntag und die Veranstalter hoffen
auf mehrere hunderttausend Besuch er
Rene Weller war ein ordentlicher Boxer
immerhin Welt und Europameister bei
seiner selbst Inszenierung ließ er aber
einfach nichts aus
glitzershorts im Ring dicke Goldkette
Macho Pose wovella war war die Show für
den Boulevard war der schöne René
spielte sogar eine Hauptrolle der Film
hieß Macho Man und gilt heute als
Kultfilm weil er so grausam schlecht war
jetzt ist er im Alter von 69 Jahren
gestorben Andreas linker erinnert
Rene Willis größte Erfolg Weltmeister
1983 im Superfedergewicht durch Ko in
der ersten Runde
von 55 Profi kämpfen gewann Welle 52
doch in Erinnerung bleibt vor allem
seine Extravaganz die Rolle des
Frauenhelden aber nur zu gerne an
ich werde wenigen der ausgezogen bis
aussieht als angezogen
er hatte verstanden dass er auffallen
musste um populär zu sein auch als
singende Buchse
[Musik]
die Medien ernannten ihn zum schönen
René sehr stolz darauf dass ich nach 400
kämpfen immer noch Deutschlands
schönster Boxer sein soll
hinter Gittern landete Rene Weller auch
vier Jahre saß er ab unter anderem wegen
Kokain handelt und Hehlerei durch die
Gefängniszeit ging Wähler aber nicht k.o
genau wie in allen seinen Kämpfen also
ich habe viel Spaß in meinem Leben
gehabt und ich bereue nichts alles was
ich tat wollte ich und alles was ich
wollte tat ich
Rene Welle starb jetzt im Alter von 69
Jahren an den Folgen seiner
Demenzerkrankung
dann kommen wir jetzt zur hockeyheim
Norbert der läuft sehr gut für die
deutschen Männer aber bestens für die
Frauen ja du sagst es drei Spiele drei
Siege 14:0 Tore die Vize Europameisterin
in Top Form gestern Abend in
Mönchengladbach ein souveränes 5:0 gegen
Irland Deutschland Gruppen erster und
spielt morgen im Halbfinale gegen
Belgien
verschwindet Freude über herrliche
Treffer hier schon das brillante 2:0
durch Pauline Heinz Ball Annahme und
Abschluss ein Hockey geht nicht kurios
danach dem Wechsel zwei von Kapitän in
nickel Lorenz fast identisch erzielte
Strafe eckentreffer zweimal genau in den
linken Torwinkel sieben Minuten vor
Schluss dann noch das 15:0 durch
jette-schütz morgen Abend dann schon das
Halbfinale gegen Belgien
und gleich geht es für die deutschen
Männer um den Finaleinzug das Spiel
gegen Frankreich ab 19.30 im Livestream
bei sportstudio.de
ebenfalls in der Ko-Runde bei einer
Heim-EM die deutschen Volleyballerinnen
die haben gestern Abend in Düsseldorf
zwar gegen Tschechien mit zwei zu drei
verloren stehen aber dennoch im
Achtelfinale und jetzt zur
Leichtathletik WM in Budapest bislang
keine deutschen Medaillen die Olympia
zweite Christine Putins wurde im Diskus
Finale gestern Abend 6 und Hochspringer
Tobias Potti trotz einer mitreißenden
Vorstellung 5 Norbert König in Budapest
wo bleiben sie denn die deutschen
Medaillen
1 Wahlen wahrscheinlich noch im Safe der
ungarischen Veranstalter es sei denn ein
deutscher hirnläufer schafft nachher um
zehn vor zehn über die Stadionrunde ein
kleines Wunder aber das joshuaco und
Sehnsucht im Finale gegen Superstar
Karsten stehen wird das ist schon jetzt
ein toller Erfolg der andere Joshua der
Hartmann wird dagegen grübeln warum er
heute Vormittag trotz starker
Vorleistungen seinen 200 Meter Vorlauf
vergeigt hat und ausgeschieden ist aber
unabhängig von deutschen erfolgen hoffen
wir auf Englisch tolle Momente wie
gestern beim Sensationssieg der
hawaiianischen diskuswerferinnen lau
Lauda tausaga mit 69,5 Metern oder bei
der Hochsprung Show von Olympia Sieger
vier goldene werden heute abend erkämpft
hier in Budapest wer sie erkämpft das
zeigen wir Ihnen ausführlich hier im ZDF
danke Norbert 19:25 sehen wir uns wieder
live aus Budapest danke genau
jetzt ein kleines Tier Rätsel es hat ein
ganz langen Hals lange Beine aber keine
Flecken trotzdem ist es eine Giraffe
eine kleine noch sie ist im
US-Bundesstaat Tennessee einfach ohne
die typischen Flecken zur Welt gekommen
das ist eine absolute Seltenheit gut
drei Wochen ist die kleine alt und
entwickelt sich auch einfarbig prächtig
und auch das Rätsel welcher Film
Deutschland bei den Oscars vertritt ist
gelöst es wird das Lehrerzimmer eine
zdf-koproduktion viel Glück und damit
sind wir bei den Lottozahlen die
Gewinnzahlen lauten 9 10 13 26 28 45
Superzahl ist die 6 weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF
Text auf Seite 557
der Wetterumschwung zu kühlerem Wetter
Naht mehr dazu gleich von es den terli
Marietta Slomka hat um 22 Uhr das heute
schon mal für sie im Interview
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Harbeck auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ja an der
kommenden Nacht in den Frühstunden kommt
im Westen erster Regen auf ansonsten ist
es aber durchweg trocken die
Temperaturen sinken dabei auf 20 Grad im
Südwesten hier deutlich milder als im
Norden da 12 Grad morgen dann in den
Morgenstunden Schauer ganz im Westen zum
Nachmittag kommen hier Gewitter auf und
auch im Norden kommen Gewitter auf die
dann zum Abend allmählich ostwärts
sondern ansonsten im Osten und im Süden
aber viel Sonnenschein bei höchsten
Temperaturen über der 30 Grad Marke am
heißesten im Südwesten bei 35 Grad und
hier wieder der Hinweis dass es eine
extreme Wärmebelastung deutlich kühler
mit 23 Grad Richtung Schleswig-Holstein
ja und der Umschwung dann am Freitag mit
Hals heftigen Unwettern stark Regen
größerem Hagel und Sturmböen was sich
dann am Samstag im Süden weiter
fortsetzt
einen schönen Abend